aujourd'hui du fameux Conseil national
de la refondation voulue par Emmanuel
Macron qui vise à débattre et trouver
des solutions pour des enjeux du
quotidien ça sert à quoi mon avis a pas
grand chose pour être raisonnable je
pense qu'Emmanuel Macron qui a bien
senti que l'Assemblée nationale a été
rééquilibrée par le vote des Français à
faire entrer massivement le
rassemblement national et cette
contourner le fonctionnement logique des
institutions que ce soit le Parlement
français le CESU pour monter des gadgets
qualifié de trucs ou de bidules par
l'opposition cette nouvelle instance est
boudée par la majorité des partis
politiques de droite et de gauche côté
syndicat seul la CFDT avec Laurent
Berger a finalement choisi le dialogue
ils sont pas là en tort parce que quand
on a un mandat on a pour représenter par
les mêmes venir dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord quand on n'est pas là faut pas
après expliquer que on n'a pas été
consulté ou que c'est trop vertical ou
trop ceci outre cela et formule de bon
sens qui dit que les absents ont
toujours tort sur les masques nous nous
sommes trompés ni plus ni moins le met à
coule pas d'Olivier Véran dans un livre
qui sort aujourd'hui dans part de là les
vagues ce pays il est par terre c'est
effrayant ce que nous voyons chaque
matin l'hôpital la justice la police et
on nous bassine sur le char à voile ou
le jet privé vous trouvez que c'est
sérieux il affirme qu'il n'a jamais
cherché au début à cacher la pénurie de
masque il confie également avoir été
soumis à un stress permanent lors de la
première vague en 2020 et avoir touché
du doigt le burn-out ses rochers ne sont
pas là par hasard et empêche toute
circulation
chaque pierre pèserait plus de 300 kg il
y en a sur environ 400 mètres
une solution radicale pour mettre fin à
ce genre de scène
du mouvement tout à fait et il continue
le combat et nous continuons le combat
avec lui et je suis sûr et je note
dessus je partage son positionnement je
crois que les faits nous donneront
raison et les Français finiront par nous
donner raison sur le moyen terme puis à
Nice le policier auteur d'un tir mortel
hier est en garde à vue les forces de
l'ordre peuvent faire usage de leur arme
en cas de légitime défense si leur vie
est menacée mais depuis 2017 un autre
cas est prévu par la loi si les
occupants sont susceptibles de perpétrer
dans leur fuite des attentes à leur vie
ou alors intégrité physique ou à celle
d'autrui c'est le signal que dans notre
pays tout est permis voilà et que
aujourd'hui les délinquants savent très
bien que la justice est de leur côté
donc je crois qu'il est temps de rompre
avec le dupont-morettisme voilà avec le
laxisme judiciaire il est temps
d'arrêter de subir et de se mettre à
sévirer le policier lorsqu'il tire s'il
pas pour tirer le tire pas pour tuer il
tire pour se défendre lui
ou les autres personnes on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que dans bien nombre
des cas le policier de victimes il passe
coupable et ça c'est inacceptable dans
la profondeur que nous sommes
waouh comme ça
queen is on the
magicali retient son souffle tous les
regards sont tournés vers Balmoral c'est
là où se trouve la reine Elizabeth II
les médecins se disent préoccupés
lorsqu'elle a reçu l'histoire pour sa
prise de fonction en tant que première
ministre et bien beaucoup ont remarqué
des bleus sur le dos de sa main comme
des traces de perfusion alors pour
l'instant on ne sait pas vraiment ce
qu'elle a au jour d'aujourd'hui et tout
le monde s'attend d'un moment à l'autre
à la terrible annonce de la disparition
de la reine donc voilà certains
annoncent même prédisent même que ça
pourrait être déjà fait et on apprend à
l'instant par une dépêche de l'AFP
sourcée de bucking Palace et bien que la
reine Elizabeth II est décédé c'est donc
le prince Charles qui va lui succéder à
la reine Elisabeth II laisse un grand
vide
aujourd'hui la couronne est transmise
comme elle l'a déjà été au cours de ces
1000 dernières années un nouveau menacé
un nouveau chef d'État Sa Majesté le roi
Charles II